there's not only the scent of labu in
the air here in the northern tehran
neighborhood of dubont there's the scent
of hope here too since the sanctions
against Iran were lifted so has the mood
of many of the Capitals residents here
they can find escape from the smoke and
crowds of the metropolis no matter we
haven't seen any practical changes yet
but the mood has changed people's
sentiments and everyone at the bazaar is
much more optimistic I'm sorry boys are
yehuda pushpin evil judo mother is very
understudied in Kanyama [ __ ] we're
expecting that our situation will really
improve prices need to come down so that
the economy can strengthen nothing like
that has happened yet [ __ ] there was a
point for the plane and I shouldn't
razia mean I'm care more at most of all
we need more job opportunities for
university graduates for example for
doctors so many are unemployed young
people here are so talented that should
be better utilized shyness the father
Bashar the government needs to deliver
soon if it wants to maintain its
citizens support and their expectations
are high President rouhani has made a
lot of promises to the people here in
Iran and easing of tensions not only in
the relations with the international
community but also in the country itself
more prosperity and more personal
freedoms as well however that is exactly
what the country's hardliners want to
prevent and distill them who have the
majority in parliament and many of the
president's plans would likely fail a
loosening of the Islamic dress code or
the censorship of social media for
instance would not be approved by the
conservative majority in parliament
despite the latest international
agreements in fact the Conservatives are
fervently trying to prevent the
relaxation of iran's foreign policy from
affecting the country's domestic
attitude but many here believe that the
parliamentary election set for the end
of februari could change
all that Bella's are moussaka and how
about a fairly between year for Saturday
the next election will result in a
parliament it is more in line with the
president OCS remember so problems will
be more easily resolved I'm us within
your camera handy until now rouhani was
completely occupied by the nuclear
agreement and the lifting of sanctions
muscular Carol now that he has achieved
all that he can take on other issues
that our family has stabled I like you
in my cell Hampshire dish I had destash
for a year call right by the hand boss
wish not everyone here in Java and feels
so positive about the future their hopes
have been dashed all too often in the
past but after so many years of
stagnation at least some here finally
have the feeling again that much more as
possible